nous sommes en pleine mer noire la
défense aérienne russe repousser un
assaut de missiles sur sa flotte
ce navire de guerre de classe kinda est
alors mobilisé ce n'est pour l'instant
qu'un exercice un de plus mais en plein
regain de tensions avec l'ukraine ces
manoeuvres pourraient être interprétées
comme des provocations
ce vendredi des échanges de tirs ont été
entendus à l'est dans le donbass et
toute la nuit
l'ukraine dit avoir été victime de 20
violation du cessez le feu par les
séparatistes pro russes qui eux rapporte
27 tirs de l'armée de kiev la veille
c'est une école maternelle qui a été
touché et là encore les deux camps se
renvoient la balle côté ukrainien ont
dit avoir été attaqués
on s'apprêtait à aller travailler je
vais comme 2014 2015 il ya eu un énorme
rugissement ce n'était pas loin j'ai
regardé par la fenêtre les gens disaient
que c'était quelque part
à côté de la maternelle nous sommes a
dit
écoutez russes ont diffusé des images en
boucle en expliquant que les
séparatistes pro russes ont seulement
riposté
en rentrant du travail j'ai entendu un
bang je n'ai rien compris et puis je me
suis venu
la tension ne retombe pas pour ce samedi
la russie annonce de nouvelles
manoeuvres de ses forces stratégiques
avec des tirs de missiles balistiques et
de croisière pendant ce temps